all right guys
bang bang i've got hydra here how are
you i'm well man how you doing
i'm doing great we're doing this uh the
week of the bitcoin conference which is
always fun
uh i said that you could feel the energy
in miami you walk down the streets you
don't know if they're bitcoiners or just
people on uh
a wannabe spring break but uh people are
excited or the
or the paul logan mayweather fight
who do you think wins uh you know if if
paul logan wins it's like
bitcoin losing to a [ __ ] coin
[Laughter]
pretty good all right you work at
okay coin you guys de-listed
bitcoin sv and bitcoin cash earlier this
year
why did you do that and what was kind of
the thought process leading into that
decision
yeah so um our it was a it was a
thought that we went through for quite
quite a bit we debated it and eventually
we decided we were we were going to do
something about it
i think the trigger for us was you know
the the attack so to speak on bitcoin
core developers
and that ip war essentially and that got
us thinking a little more about
branding how people could potentially be
confused like if you look at okay coin
over the last 12 months we've you know
had a pretty significant effort in
attracting people who were on the fence
about crypto
and i think we timed it well because you
know then then came the bull run and it
helped
accelerate that that adoption what
happens when you bring new retail into
your platform is
you know at least corporate from our
side internally we feel a sense of
responsibility
you bring in new investors it's
important for us to
point them to the right things and
what we noticed with new retail was they
would look at
bitcoin bitcoin cash and bsv and
wouldn't be able to distinguish between
the three they would almost feel
uh and this came through in surveys and
you know other customer service feedback
is hey look there are three bitcoin
logos so they must all be bitcoin and so
we added them to our portfolio
and that unintentional trading investing
buying was
was troubling and we wanted to make sure
we play our part in protecting that
investor base now naturally when we
when we started to you know evaluate
this stuff the
the debate internally was do we do
something from a product standpoint to
differentiate
and that's a big can of worms that we
weren't ready to open yet
we'll explain what you mean by just like
what those could have been
and why that's not a viable path could
we have
you know had a text at the bottom of
those assets that said hey this is a
fork of bitcoin and what have you
but then the debate was well the
branding is still pretty identical so
how do you explain that
and oftentimes people might not read a
small disclaimer they might just go
by you know the visual cues so generally
speaking if
i think the sentiment was how do we
protect priorities protect the investors
and as we figure out what what we could
do to distinguish these assets
from a product standpoint let's de-list
them let's start the conversation
because one you know ideal approach
would be convincing the bch bsv
communities
to rebrand those assets even if they're
not going to rename it they should stop
using the bitcoin
branding and i i know that's a pretty
controversial sort of angle
but we think that's one that's really
important you know bitcoin is an open
source
uh ecosystem but that doesn't mean you
can start using their branding uh
bitcoin branding and start applying it
on different forks
so to be clear here i think this is a
very important distinction
okay coin and the team and the product
isn't taking a position necessarily on
the merit of the projects it's simply
saying
hey we have customers who trust our
product they sign up
they attach their bank accounts they
give us information
all the things that are regulated
us-based exchange needs
and they're coming into our product and
they're trying to buy bitcoin
but some of them are buying something
else
simply because they're confused by the
naming or the branding
and so rather than be adversarial to
those communities and saying hey you
have to change the name or
whatever you're simply protecting the
users
and we'll continue to re-evaluate it if
something changes where you think that
users won't be
confused that's right is that fair yeah
that's absolutely fair
and uh you know we got we got great
feedback from the community and of
course we upset the bchbsv communities
and the message was look we're very
supportive of your ecosystems just
stop using the bitcoin branding tilting
the bitcoin logo towards the left
doesn't mean you have your own brand
can i ask a serious question did you
guys
care that they were upset no okay
i can speak for myself i can't speak on
behalf of the company
but uh generally speaking no we weren't
upset because because you expected it we
expected
look anything you do in crypto you're
going to have 20 people who are unhappy
with what you did
so that it just comes with the territory
but generally speaking
um i i think we have to take a stance
and this was
one that we felt was really important in
the pursuit of protecting investors
and what would be the parameters
for potentially realistic i don't
obviously you'd have to do it there's a
whole team that evaluates this etc
but is it like a renaming rebranding
type thing and oh hey
the assets would be up for re-evaluation
of being relisted or is it
um i'd liken it to uh uh
trump being banned from twitter forever
regardless of what happens in the future
right it sounds like not so much the the
latter more the former of there's a
reevaluation process if things change
you're right there is a compliance team
there's a legal team there's a listings
team they
do the proper evaluation but generally
speaking i think what would trigger
a re-evaluation of this uh of these two
assets
is uh a rebranding even if they don't
change the name which is less
problematic than the the look and feel
if they were to update their look and
feel and change the logo so it's not a
blatant copy of
of the bitcoin branding i think there
would be a conversation and there would
be appetite
again i can't speak for the entire team
but i generally think the company would
be very supportive of us reevaluating
that
got it when you think about the listing
kind of process for exchanges in general
you guys have actually been
pretty unique i think uh obviously
you've got the bitcoins the ethers right
the
what i'll call kind of the blue chips of
the space
you've taken this stand that we just
talked about around bsv
and bch but you've also added things
like
stacks which is i think you were the
first people in the united states to
list
and it has a rabid community it's got
kind of a different
element to it than some of these other
assets like
how does that process work i think a lot
of people were like what is the process
of an asset going from
hey somebody created this it's working
or being adopted or got a community
it's actually getting onto an exchange
is that something where you guys reach
out to them they reach out to you
you have mutual friends like just how
does that work well in our case you know
we did have a relationship with manip
my previous firm where i was working as
a head of growth at blockchain
uh you know i introduced money to to
that team and we ended up
uh providing wallet support you know the
blockchain wallet started to support
stacks uh
earlier version of stacks so there was a
relationship there the general to answer
your question about listings the way
this
gets triggered typically is in a number
of different ways one is we have a
dedicated listings team and they're
going out there and evaluating assets
very proactively
assets and communities once that
evaluation is done or whether it's done
through
you know the marketing or the bd teams
where we surface something up
what happens is we have a compliance
team and a legal team
and then there's an executive committee
and those three
groups evaluate uh the asset
in particular the the thing that of
course at a very high level that we look
for is is it deemed a security or a
utility token
does it pass the howie test and when
those
areas are are checkboxed then we
evaluate the rest of the
you know the artifacts or the you know
things that are related to any listings
can we list it can we build the right
sort of product experience uh what is it
that the community is seeking
if we're not the first to list can we
deliver some unique value in any way
shape or form
so those are the questions that that are
typically asked but we are a regulated
exchange we're regulated in the us and
in some
global markets so naturally we have to
start with a compliance process and
it's a very rigorous process on our on
our side
and when you list the traditional assets
right that's kind of table stakes at
this point
um what about when you go and list kind
of a
outlier type asset right outlier just
being hey it's not one of the top
five or six assets is that something
where you see
user sign ups if you do you see like
more engagement on social media like
what's some of the
impact of those assets or is just no
impact at all
it's it's a mixed bag look every asset
we list we hope there's demand
uh sometimes that demand is instant
sometimes as a platform we have to um
we have to create discoverability what i
mean by that is
educating our existing base that there's
an asset this is a high quality asset
and why do we think that
of course anything we say and do uh you
know there's a there's a red tape around
it's not investment advice all we can do
is educate people and help them discover
it
and let them make that investment choice
or that trading choice
so um it's it's a mixed bag with some
assets we've seen a lot of growth with
the other assets you know we haven't
seen the velocity that we
we had anticipated but generally
speaking
overall you do see a spike in new users
can actually especially in our case it
also depends on where
your firm is and what part of evolution
you you're at
but for us uh arguably we've been around
for a while but in the u.s and western
markets we are still
a new brand and we're making our inroads
so
uh by by listing new assets we attract
these communities
and they're then able to come into the
oki coin ecosystem
and and experience the product and the
hope is always like we delight them from
the
from the rest of the experiences and
they stay this is like
the main topic i want to talk about
today which is when you're building a
business
especially an exchange business that has
retail users
there's this element of uh trust between
the user and a centralized platform
there's a couple of different ways you
can build that trust right
one is you can go get a bunch of
regulatory approvals and just hey if
it's regulated then there has to be some
level of uh adherence to rules
um and kind of risk management and all
that right you guys have that
um as do many exchanges that are based
in the united states
but there's also marketing and product
and
i think that there's this element of you
could have great marketing
but a horrible product all hype no
substance
not a great situation to be in you could
have a great product
no marketing meaning all substance no
hype
you'll build a business right it'll take
a really long time because no one knows
about you
and so what you literally are doing is
you're only dependent on word of mouth
and to get that flywheel started takes a
long time the best businesses
have great marketing and great product
right they marry the best of those two
worlds
how do you think about that balance of
as you're building up the business
is it marketing and then that drives
product does the product drive the
marketing
is there maybe not as much of a
connection between one driving the other
and their two
distinct and separate efforts like just
what's the relationship there and how do
you see
you guys being successful you know kind
of rolling out those two different
bodies of work
so it's it's an interesting question
because i've had so many different
experiences
there have been times where you know the
marketing is leading sort of the charge
where
other times there's there's a stronger
product
and an ideal state is that they're both
at the same time but it doesn't it's not
usually the starting point the starting
point is like there's an imbalance
in the case of ok coin if i reflect
back on last year i think
i can safely say that marketing led and
and pushed
our product into a certain place and
then now if you look at the last six
months within you know 2021
product is getting ahead so marketing
needs to catch up
and um if you look at us last year we
were just an advanced trading platform
sort of
uh you can come in and place you know
different order types so on and so forth
and you need to do charting and
uh what have you now if you open the new
coin app
it's a very simplified experience it's
uh for any novice who is coming into
crypto for the first time
you can go from zero to having a crypto
portfolio very quickly
so during last year when we didn't have
that product marketing had to work
harder and it had to work harder in
building the right partnerships we did
work with unstoppable domains
stacks avac so on and so forth and now i
think we're
you know we're getting to a place where
there is the balance
is is you know where we might be able to
achieve a good balance
and the product in many ways is ahead
now we have a uh
the first decentralized staking product
any exchange or any platform has what i
mean by that is
you come to a kickcoin and you can go
into these d5 protocols
through our through our ecosystem and
one one thing that we make
that is super appealing to new investors
is we remove all the gas fees and fees
related to it
so if you do it on a dex or what have
you you're you know exposing yourself to
high fees we removed that we realized
that's not a great experience
so in in those instances the product is
ahead and when i look at the marketing
side
we the job is not done yet we have to do
better storytelling
we have to do better life cycle
marketing so people understand that the
next part of their journey perhaps is
taking and what is the value there
when you think about um the product
one of the things i know you guys did
you mentioned a little bit is the
unstoppable domains partnership
uh my understanding of this is that uh
you essentially
took unstoppable domains the ability to
have crypto sent to this
human readable domain and now support it
on the exchange so if i want to send
uh a bitcoin to somebody who has an ok
coin
uh account and wallet i don't have to
type in the bitcoin address i can
instead
send it to hyder.crypto for example
right
is that something that it's like oh this
is just a great
you know improvement of the user
experience for our users and that's why
we go do it
is there some other driver or evaluation
process like to me that's like
so forward thinking to say like hey
we probably should stop using these you
know kind of random
strings of letters and numbers it's not
a great experience
i today still you know your heart starts
beating a little bit faster
i really hope i'm sending it to the
right address uh
but just like www.you know whatever you
start to solve that's like how does that
happen
so with unstoppable we started with the
utility just like you described it we we
knew that
uh something had to be done on our
platform at least
in terms of creating more
interoperability but making it easier
for people to move crypto around
so if you're on boarding a friend who
hasn't been in crypto
yet and uh the experience you know first
off you're convincing them that crypto
is the next big thing this is a new
future of finance and what have you and
then you get to the wallet addresses and
you're showing this archaic way of
sending and receiving so how do you
convince people
truly that this is the next innovation
and and that didn't feel right
and what unstoppable is doing is great
with human readable addresses we felt
we should be one of the first exchanges
to integrate this so that people can
move crypto around
freely and with the hope that you're
going to invite a bunch of other friends
and it'll be easier for you to get them
there now of course somebody has to go
to unstoppable domains and
buy a domain but i think they've made it
pretty easy to do so and i think it's a
great long-term investment because
you're basically securing your digital
identity so to speak or real estate
because as you know
you can use it for sending receiving but
you can also publish content on them
and it's a fully decentralized um
you know domain system naming system so
we start with utility but the other
piece of this
when i spoke about interoperability is
you know unstoppable
uh is supported by 40 plus wallets
as a platform why wouldn't we integrate
unstoppable domains so
people who have those wallet accounts
they can now go in and out of our
platform very easily
and do their trading do their investing
staking so on and so forth
and bring their crypto back to their you
know their preferred wallet
and that in itself was a was a
no-brainer for us
how do you think about uh the paypal's
um the robin hoods of the world not
allowing people to withdraw
versus it almost sounds like you guys
open it up hey look we want you to be
able to withdraw to go into staking to
do all these various things and it's
more of like an open system is that an
intentional thing or is that just
something that kind of happened i
couldn't speak for paypal but before i
give you a response there i'm still not
uh you know sure why
paypal has bch listed and they didn't go
after this problem because i
i feel like uh you know they have a
bigger
responsibility to protect retail because
largely speaking
they just have a much bigger customer
base but in the case of
paypal and robinhood one reason could be
they don't have
proper wallet support on their platforms
yet i know
i've heard or read that robinhood is
working on their
their wallet product i don't know what
paypal is going to do in that context
you can expect these these traditional
finance companies
to create wall gardens it's um you know
it's something that that we've seen
with other firms so crypto in its nature
needs to be more open
uh we talk a lot internally about
interoperability
let's be honest when you think about
equities or stocks you probably have a
td ameritrade account but you also have
a fidelity account and you probably also
have a charles schwab account
as an investor because you know you
might have your 401k
and one through your employer you might
be buying stocks on another and you
might be doing something else on the
third one
same is true with crypto you don't we
don't we shouldn't expect the world that
they're gonna have one or two products
that they own on their phone or
or or their laptop you know it's it's
all right to have multiple products and
if this is the case
one of the key value propositions for
crypto is
creating this interoperability where you
and i can transact with each other
regardless of where we are and there's
no bank involved
well if that's true then we should also
think about embracing interoperability
in other ways between different
platforms because
naturally people are going to want to
move uh move value around
and i think we as platforms compare to
traditional finance
have this responsibility to drive that
so it's easier it's faster it's cheaper
if i had to transfer money out of
fidelity put it in charge prompt it's a
process
and there's fees related to that what's
up guys bang bang
i hope you're enjoying this conversation
but before we go any further i want to
quickly tell you about today's sponsor
blockfi blockfy's got four different
financial products for crypto investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
8.6 apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
you can use our cryptocurrency exchange
and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe you get bitcoin back
rather than cash back or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user
i think you will be too when you go to
blockfy.com
pomp again blockfy.com pomp go check it
out and let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it one of
the things that a lot of those charles
schwab's fidelities of the world have
done a fantastic job with it
research education uh just content in
general i know that you guys have
started to spend more time on how do you
actually educate the folks who come in
right
um i almost think of it as as they come
in on a true
retail uh i'll say amateur not
necessarily
skills right but more so just in their
understanding they're
new to this industry they're new to the
assets and so
uh it seems like you guys feel like
there's a huge advantage to being able
to educate them on
what the assets are what the value
propositions are what the risks are
and then the things that they can do
with those assets whether it's staking
or something else
so maybe talk a little bit just about
like the education and how much
of that comes from you guys as a
platform versus from you know
other things that they may consume so
so it's a great question in a sense
because i think about this a lot
in crypto largely speaking we think
about creating
content that feeds the crypto natives
there's a lot for us to learn from
traditional finance
what i mean by that is there are signals
and things that
investors on the equity side and stocks
consume that
works for us for example we have
analysts ratings for every stock out
there
and yeah we don't have the same rhythm
we don't have quarterly earnings reports
on and so forth but
i think there's this product missing
where you know you can
you can look at the maybe there's like
28 analysts out there right and they're
uh they're evaluating most of these
cryptos and the markets
and based on that they're putting a a
price target
or they're putting a buy sell signal on
them into the block
started to do that i know they were
doing it with bitcoin and some of the
top assets and that was great
and uh i you know i know they they have
an open api and other platforms can use
them
but i think there is a lot in
traditional finance we should look at
and try and replicate because it it
works even the nomenclature
we don't need to create new language the
language is already there
the instruments are the same they're not
that different
so when we think about education we're
really looking at traditional finance
and saying hey
not everything is bad there there's a
lot of goodness there let's let's grab
that goodness and bring it in
so it's easier to to you know
quote-unquote uh on board the
cryptocuries
to the platform so that's how we think
about education
uh we're trying to have a very
deliberate effort to move away from
creating content that is for crypto
natives only
so trying to basically speak to somebody
in the language that they understand
without having to have kind of prior
knowledge is really important
yes yeah you recently rebranded as well
is that somewhat related as well in
terms of trying to
kind of have a look and feel and and
level of trust that they would expect
from like a traditional finance consumer
application
did somebody just not like the logo or
like what what was kind of the thought
process behind the rebrand and then like
what impact have you seen from that so
far
yeah look i i come from a traditional
marketing background i started my career
at uh on madison avenue working for a
bunch of old school ad agencies and
uh the bigger opportunity i see in
crypto is that the marketing muscle is
not fully built yet
uh we're improving but we're not there
yet where consumer finances are
one of some of the you know larger
consumer brands are
so when it comes to a rebrand what we
felt was missing in the previous
one was it served as a logo
but we weren't confident it really
served as our identity
and we were also not confident that it
self served this
new identity we had formed over the last
12 months where we were doing things
differently as part of us now being
headquartered in san francisco
so it was you know we we felt that we
needed to change
but it that change didn't need to be
just because we were doing something
different
it was more about what is our intention
and
there was an intention missing in the
previous brand and we wanted to bring
some intention
into this new brand that was reason
number one reason number two is
finance doesn't need to be boring uh we
can have fun with it
um i there are other brands that are
having a lot of fun with it and we
wanted to participate in that
uh when we think about content creation
and so on and so forth
there's an opportunity for us to create
stuff that's just entertaining
and we wanted to uh introduce a platform
a brand platform that enables us that
gives us a permission to start doing
that
so if you look at you know our new web
page and you look at some of the design
stuff like if we scroll down
you know we've got we've got stuff
that's just hopefully more pleasing to
the eye
it's also more risky uh where you'll
notice we're not using any finance blue
that was very deliberate
so i think it's it's our whole
goal right now with the rebrand is to
give it intention
uh give it a reason for why we're
rebranding and
and then build on that why does every
finance company use blue
i don't finance blue you said that like
it was like new york giants
blue like it's just like everyone knows
what it is when they hear it look i i
didn't work in finance for
you know uh historically but uh there
was a time where i started asking that
question
and a few people started uh mentioning
the
the term finance blue and then i started
exploring and i realized wow there are a
bunch of like
big large finance firms that are that
are blue even in crypto
a lot of the legacy firms are still
using blue in their color palette
and i'd the the notion behind having
find
the blue in finance is that it gives you
a sense of calmness and trust and so on
and so forth
but i think human beings have evolved i
think we can get away with more
being more risky or being a little
different it's kind of like in the
supermarket they say that the reason why
the
fruit and produce is up front because
when you walk and you sell the bright
colors and supposedly like makes you
hungry or something it's true
really yeah that's wild i i fall in that
trap every time
they also say what don't go shopping
when uh when you're hungry right because
you're buying way more
way more that you're not gonna eat yeah
it's so funny
uh what do you like where do you guys go
from here right so you've
uh kind of built a product that i think
is pretty compelling
i think that you've got a marketing team
now that seems to really understand
hey we should talk to people in a unique
way
we should stand for something right not
because it's a marketing exercise but
because we actually believe this stuff
and it's okay to state what we believe
but when you have the product in the
marketing like
what's next
meet the customer where they are that's
a really important
piece so for example traditionally
speaking when we think about customer
service
we we think okay well most of your
inquiries are going to come from the
help desk or you know systems that
you've built
and what you'll what we all can probably
agree on is
that's often not the case all the time
when we have problems with any product
the first thing we probably do is go to
our preferred social media platform
and we complain there so naturally when
we think about our
our experience because in marketing we
think about experiences we're not
thinking about hey just messaging it's a
overall end-to-end experience and
in that sense i think we're we're really
looking at our customer service
and how we can meet the customer where
they are and make sure that they get a
response from us
we're in the business of money we help
people
choose investments get access to markets
that comes with a fundamental
responsibility that you're gonna
you're gonna build trust with your
investor base and your community
and you're gonna serve them well and so
there's a
big focus right now at the company to be
very community driven
be very customer obsessed and meet them
where they are
and the second part of meeting them
where they are is learning and observing
on
things that they are looking for that
we're missing today
could it be a product feature could it
be a new asset
it could be you know a way of doing
something within our platform so
we're as part of that what we're doing
is listening
uh there are rigorous exercises
happening across different surfaces
where we gather this data there's a
research arm at the company that's
evaluating some of these uh these
signals
and that feedback makes it back into the
rest of the organization and
uh you know we take action what would
you say the biggest thing that the users
want you guys to do that you haven't
done yet is
is there like something that you're just
like we're working on it but like yeah
we
we hear you look the the new app was was
a big
uh big requirement i think a lot of
customers were hoping that we would
simplify
uh that experience payment rails was
another one if you look at the product
last year we didn't have ach
which is your ability to just connect
your bank account using your username
password of your banking
banking account essentially there were
other payment gateways that we
introduced
like apple pay and so on and so forth so
we've met that side of the demand the
second part to that was hey can you
simplify the experience because we're
not a lot of the customers we were
attracting were just confused between
the different order types and what have
you so the new interface
is much simpler it's really designed
it's uncomfortably simple
and the job is not done i think we need
to even further simplify it
but that was the second big demanded
product
so we've delivered on that and i think
you'll see iterations
uh over the next 30 days now as soon as
we launched the new app
most customers were uh asking for
staking support within
the new app so good they want to make
money right away they want to make money
and and i think we we should have that
launch pretty soon
so that's one that we're excited about
and uh
we're also thinking about other
experiences uh beyond just what the
customers are asking oftentimes i think
we both can agree
some of the really sticky products
don't often get incubated from
customer requests in fact most customers
don't know what they want until they see
it arguably
so there is work that we're doing um
to to distinguish our platform such that
there is like core utility that just
differentiates us when you come to us
we're not like every other platform
you're not just coming to us
because of our one of our biggest value
propositions which is fees
a lot of customers come to us because
they're placing orders and they're like
look you guys are
your fees are very appealing so beyond
that there is stuff that we're working
on
uh to to entertain people to have let
them have fun when they come
enter into crypto markets and get
introduced to these concepts
which it goes back to you know meet the
customer where they are
a lot of the new investors are younger
folks
and and they want certain gamification
in the platform
uh and such and they want to be able to
talk about this stuff with each other
so yeah there's there's stuff beyond
customer feedback that we're excited
about
makes a ton of sense one of the things i
think really caught my attention early
on with you guys was
uh you've been funding bitcoin
developers talk a little bit about that
effort and like where did that idea come
from and then how's that been going
so with bitcoin core development uh this
this effort started before i joined
okay coin last year i think i joined
somewhere in march uh this is an effort
that's really close to our ceo and
there's another person
on our team who's driving this on a
day-to-day basis
there wasn't any commercial intent
behind why we did this
what excited me about this effort and
part of the reason why i decided to join
okcoin is there's a lot of work that
happens
whether investment or product or what
have you that
actually doesn't have a commercial
intent
it's not about revenue it's not about
fees it's about doing the right
thing so our belief internally that
that is pretty clear to everyone is we
believe that
bitcoin serves as the foundational layer
to all crypto markets
when there's volatility in bitcoin
markets there's volatility elsewhere
in all all the rest of the alts so
it it it comes with that that you know
as a platform it comes with a sense of
responsibility that we
must fund the bitcoin core developers
because they're doing great work
they're essentially uh you know
developing these markets and and
maturing them over time
so somebody's got to fund them and as a
platform
we feel that corporate obligation we
feel that it's our sense it's our
character
uh and and when we deploy some of this
uh investment
we are not seeking any uh you know we're
not
seeking any commercial intent uh there
is none
and what we've really liked about our
dev grants is the the idea that you know
there was one developer we funded before
that
she was funded by uh bitmex and now she
was recently
for this year funded by gemini which is
a great sign right like we're all
working together
uh to to support these uh these great
developers amity is our name um
which which i think is is really
authentic and true to true to our
character how do you pick who to find
um it's a pretty rigorous process i'm
probably not the best person to answer
that you know hong our ceo is speaking
at the bitcoin conference and she's
talking about this at length on a panel
so i think it's it's uh you know you'll
get more substance there than
uh than my articulation i'm sure you
know i have no clue how it's done so you
already know more than i do
yeah i mean look generally speaking we
look for really high caliber really
promising developers who
are who've demonstrated some some good
intent and
uh there's an evaluation process we look
at their
their backgrounds and such and you'll
get to hear more from hong k
on saturday if you if you tune in but
yeah there's there's a team behind this
it's not just uh it's not just done it's
not just the twitter account somebody
just
dming and saying hey i need funding no
there's like a full
process we have checkpoints with these
developers we make sure they have what
they need
is there anything we can do to make them
successful so on and so forth and we
are also very open and this is one of
the things i really like
about dev grants is it's one of the
areas within our prod
or within our company where there is
more interoperability
so others in in you know our ecosystem
in
in crypto will collaborate they'll reach
out and there's sort of like a really
friendly engagement there which which is
really great what are you personally
excited about
kind of the rest of 2021. gosh
uh so much uh i think for us
uh i'll speak to it um bless you as
uh as a marketer um
crypto and the crypto industry at large
are at this point
where i think we really need to up our
storytelling
and it's easier said than done i can sit
here and say that but executing on that
is very challenging and you
really takes a lot of soul-searching but
it also takes a lot of human investment
and capital investment
but we owe it to ourselves at this point
to to do it and make those investments
there are
there are a lot of firms that are that
are doing great work on this side and i
am hoping that the entire
industry will up level itself
but what i'm most excited about is our
ability to take this brand
and really do a lot of creative stuff
with it
a lot of creative storytelling and meet
these customers where they are
culturally speaking uh so finding
you know artists finding other
collaborators we can collaborate that
doesn't seem as obvious at
at the first glance but as you go
through it you realize okay that
you know there was a purpose and there
was an intent behind this thing so
my biggest point of excitement is what
the company does with the permission we
have
the team the incredible team we've been
able to build and the budgets we have
to deploy some of the best storytelling
personally my
you know my goal whether it's us i hope
it's us
or it's another crypto firm uh since i
got into crypto one of the observations
i had was
gosh there are these phenomenal
companies and products and innovation
and none of them that we get awards but
we don't get any marketing awards
so uh you know how do we become one of
those brands there's this
uh huge marketing event that happens uh
at cannes
um and uh there's no crypto company
being nominated for those awards
and personally i'd like for okay coin to
be that company first
it would be amazing it would be such an
honor and accomplishment if we were
to be uh if we were to win any of those
whether it's a bronze
silver or a gold we'd love to bring one
home
maybe this year but even if it weren't
us
my hope is that someone in the crypto
industry will do that because it will
open us up
into a new world a lot of these consumer
companies show up there
and i think we have the opportunity to
do that
it's the same thing that probably nike
asked at some point
how do we stop selling shoes you know
how do we how do we influence culture
how do we inspire people
it's the same thing i said in one of my
blogs which is how do you teach people
you know how do you tell a company to
not sell dog food but you teach them
to love dog to to teach humans to to
love dogs
well what's that in our in our
particular context how do we show people
the future of financial empowerment how
can they generate wealth for themselves
entering these crypto markets
and and i think that's the biggest uh
you know exciting piece ahead of us
is unlocking that story regardless of
where it comes from
when you think about that what is the
impact if that story starts to be the
dominating narrative versus
price energy fud elon
you know we go down the line of all the
things that dominate headlines is that
the most important message to kind of
have dominate the headline
i don't know but it has to be a message
that's better than what we have right
now
because right now it's really polarizing
in some ways um
it's it's not as mature as it needs to
be or deserves to be
for for people to start trusting it uh
you know we came
came out of the 2017 hype
or run up and then things fizzled for a
little bit and there was a lot of
skepticism and now we've kind of gone
through that again
and i think we all have to be careful
because what we do what we support
what we put out there in the world
reflects not just on us but it reflects
on
the entire industry it goes back to the
d listing of bch and bsv for branding
reasons
if we don't do it if one of us in the
crypto industry doesn't do it then
what's the perception we're creating
if someone new comes in and they're like
oh you guys
all are excited about bitcoin
as a decentralized currency but yet
you have these three different bitcoins
there you know how do you how do you
build trust on that
so i think there's a sense of
responsibility we should all have in
in making sure we we keep some checks
and balances
i wrap up i asked everyone the same
three questions first is what is the
most important book that you've ever
read
wow um you know i usually don't say this
but the art of war was
it was probably the zoo yeah yeah uh why
that one
uh i don't know i think it's there's
there's a lot about human behavior
and and relationships in there that that
i
i find fascinating i've read it a few
times and every time i
reread it it fascinates me even more
um so that's i think that's one i think
to
to develop relationships to to manage
relationships and and
to live life i think it's an important
book it's a good read yeah to to have
from
time to time fantastic second question
is your sleep schedule comes from our
friends that ate sleep
so i sleep not at all now i sleep a lot
yeah uh
they gave me this thermo-regulated bed
uh that i've been sleeping on
and uh it's a life changer like i'm a
full-on
convert of sleep what's your sleep
schedule like
so that thermo bed that you have can i
get it for my two-year-old
because you can buy a big one and have a
two-year-old lay on it
yeah look to answer your question i
think um
it's really important to manage your
sleep really really important uh
you know managing your energy i think is
really important and it's easier said
than done
i'm really conscious of it these days
and i'm trying to improve it
of course with a two-year-old at home
it's it's a bit challenging but that's
no excuse either i think
i think we can all be disciplined about
it and what that ends up doing is your
hap your happiness level is
up your creativity is is up your
relationships are better
your ability to do your best work is
is much well positioned so i think sleep
is
sleep is really important so is working
out meditation and all that good stuff
and getting no screen time for during
your days
yeah the the no screen time is a hard
one for me
because it is uh third question you get
asked me one to finish up
is aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
absolutely a believer why well look i
think
the the recent evidence is is too
coincidental
i think it's it's coming from different
different sources
you know president obama uh said some
stuff about it a few years ago
you know as uh seeing watching some
interview from
uh from a person who served in the navy
so
it's too coincidental now that people
are
coming out with the same sort of
narrative or observations or sightings
what is unclear is
the incidents that are being reported
are those
actual aliens that we don't know but i i
do believe in the idea that there's
probably some other species i think it's
naive for us to think that
it's such a large universe and we're the
only species
like ufos and aliens together isn't
necessarily
uh how it works right you can have an
unidentified
object that flies and then not be an
alien
that's right yeah and an alien also
doesn't have to be
little green men or like you know
two-handed four like or two like
uh you know human-like creature it can
be an insect
for all we know and what would be
fascinating is an insect that's like
way smarter than us um cephalopod you
know what that is it's like a
thing that lives in the ocean they took
an intelligence test and it's the first
animal
uh in the ocean i think uh that passed
the uh intelligence test that they give
to
like kids like um all right i'm out
all right you can ask me one question to
finish up what you got for me hmm
what did you think about ok coin and our
bch bsv listing what was your
view when you saw us doing that i'd be
curious to to hear what
what your perception was i think there's
a lot of people who agree it's confusing
i think there's a lot of people who also
for either economic
or social reasons
uh and kind of social consensus and
political correctness don't do anything
about it
uh i don't think that it is uh
unfair of you to say hey our customers
are getting confused therefore we're
gonna take action
people will debate on a whole spectrum
of like here's all the things you could
have done like where's the right
decision
but they're not the people making the
decision right they're not the people
who are kind of like
uh in the game right um i i liken that
to like armchair quarterback right
monday morning quarterback it's really
easy to say i
shouldn't have done the ball to that
wide receiver look at the other one he
was wide open
idiot yeah well okay you had you play
the game with you know all these people
running at you full speed etc
uh and so i think that ultimately
uh my guess is more people will follow
my guess is that it
puts forward a very interesting
conversation
uh one where i don't have an opinion in
terms of open source
and like ip and like something that's
not even a crypto thing right it's just
like
what is the rights and best practices
and stuff around open source
ip and like can people use it can they
not i don't know there's people way
smarter than me that can figure all that
out and probably already have
but then it also brings up this thing in
the crypto industry just around like
what do we as an industry you know kind
of accept and think is right and what do
we think is not right and
uh that seems to be like you know people
in the cryptid shape much more say than
just like open source ip stuff
um and then ultimately i think it's like
if
your goal is to be very clear with your
customer base and say this is what we
stand for
it's pretty damn clear what you stand
for right like it's one of those things
where i've told you this before when
people ask me you know about okay
clients the first thing i tell them
and there's some people who are like
that's ridiculous i can't believe they
did that
but majority of people are like oh damn
okay
right and it resonates with them and so
it's like anything in life
if you stand for something you're going
to piss somebody off you're going to
annoy somebody whatever
suck it up get over it move on right and
i think that this is like a perfect
example of just like yeah of course
people are going to be upset
but the people who are upset are much
smaller group of people than the people
who actually like it and so you got to
kind of ignore the the downside and look
at
you know the who you're serving right
what is your ultimate goal what are you
optimizing for and i think that
you guys have been pretty clear about
what you're optimizing for that's okay
there's plenty of other places you want
to go do that go you know go and trade
those assets somewhere else
that's right well great that's uh great
to hear you're you're supportive
where where can we send people to find
you on the internet or more about okay
coin
uh so more about okay coin pretty simple
we have a new app you can go to the app
store and
and search for it uh one of the unique
things about the app is you can toggle
between advanced and basic mode within
one app
shameless plug of course okaycoin.com
and then you can find me on twitter
hider sf is my
it's my twitter handle pretty easy to
find me awesome man well listen thank
you so much for doing this
thanks for being in the future yeah yeah
thank you